previously on phasmophobia oh this looks
fun
oh yeah this oh yeah oh oh my god
this is way bigger than the last place
oh my god i saw a shadow in the corner
yeah yeah he's right here at the door oh
wait
journal's written in my hand says die
die die die die
whoa classroom is this like a church
bob i'll go check i guess
oh that scared me
phone ringing over here oh wait no i i
got it it's it's
bob ah there he's he was pranking us bob
was pranking us
i didn't bring the
the phone rang itself the phone rang
itself yeah
yeah if it was over here or downstairs
though it's not going to be at the same
place is it
freezing temperatures here oh coming
with the am
ep i mean
where are you down that hall that you
guys are going we're still upstairs
i gotta work on me a breath breath on me
breath
we got breath confirmed three three on
the emf
okay elizabeth miller elizabeth miller
oh we got hand print
we got a hamburger miller fingerprint
yep race band
racer banshee banshee is emf level five
wraith is spirit box one of our two
things
well so i was already getting some emf
right
yeah they were on the door you want to
get a picture of it a little yeah yeah i
could do that miller
elizabeth miller hello
i don't i don't know if that showed up
it takes it counts
okay thanks for calling show yourself
elizabeth miller are you with us my my
flashlight my flashlight's flickery
dudes
oh right left knife
[Music]
oh no oh my god it's right there oh
she's right here right here
smudge away running at five on that yes
for sure
emf5 happened so then it's a banshee
ah okay ah good uh a banshee yeah
that's fine hey guys
hey everybody oh yeah
hurry up i'm gonna close the door oh the
smudge sticks didn't stick
it didn't cleanse the area oh are you
staying
in an attempt yeah if you can get that
that'd be great all right i'll do it
all right see ya elizabeth miller kind
of sucks i'm gonna i'm gonna do it boys
i'm gonna smudge him you're gonna go
back in
i'm to smudge them you you guys find me
on the camera as i'm going
all right cool see ya we'll keep
constant radio contact nothing bad can
happen
nothing bad can happen if you smudge it
you will survive
he's dead oh oh god he's dead i'm not
dead
you will have the best funeral i'm going
in going
uh do you want like his computer once
he's gone no no no no i have a will you
can't do that
yeah there's no camera that points where
he is i'm still seeing my breath in here
oh i see his flashlight on the map on
the camera yeah
do i smudge before she shows up or do i
i'm smudging
i'm fear smudging
didn't cross it off why don't you say
her name a bit elizabeth miller
elizabeth miller elizabeth miller you
know what i'm thinking you might need a
lighter for the smudge stick
ah yeah you didn't light it now you just
got a bundle of sticks
do you think ghosts are afraid
yeah you come back out guys i don't know
if they're good
all right fine i'm so glad you spent
your time doing that
don't worry mission accomplished i was
really thinking he was going to die i
thought he was going to die we could
still just leave him yeah i can hear you
yeah we could just leave him behind and
he'd never like no one had ever seen him
no one would question it
wade's already dead so we just come back
crying a little bit we're like oh
both of our friends died in a horrible
ghost accident
oh hey i just teleported here what the
hell
uh [ __ ] hi pack it up boy
all right another good mission our
history
mission accomplished look at those
photos
look at those points man
that would have been a great round oh
there it is just about here there's
just about to get weighed away look
that's a good one
uh i think that was me look at me just
standing there like
oh no that's a good thing
template right there that's so good
ah bob's level five [ __ ] that guy you
haven't died yet have you
i literally threw myself at the banshee
and they were like nah not you
have we done bleesdale farmhouse no
bliesdale
man i don't think so a story three
bedroom farmhouse with an attic
oh no no no we've not done the attic no
etiquette
is that still amateur uh yeah one day
we'll get a tough job
what do we get to do the real [ __ ] yeah
i wanna consider like
real ghosts i'm tired of dying to pleb
ghosts i want to die to real
yeah oh hey mark hi
how's everyone doing oh
great oh wait someone do that and then
let me look let me do this over here
[Laughter]
all right it's definitely an emf one
probably
okay i grabbed that i won't be radio man
all right
ghost event emf smudge sticks again
george martinez oh yeah i was told
if we're gonna ask the ghost questions
don't say the name say the name to piss
it off or ask questions
don't do both ah okay i like doing both
like if you say george martinez and ask
a question it will only register as you
saying the name
oh we have done this okay that's not
gonna work no this is a different form
us
no it's a different slightly different
yeah all right split up you gotta be
alone
all right
i'm going up to the attic
is anyone there
can you give me a sign i live in a long
time
is that one of you yeah
that's near me yeah i turned on the
radio it was getting kind of quiet up
here
interfering with my science fiction oh
yeah oh
okay this guy nothing up in the attic
oh emf three in this bathroom we
near this water with the soap in it nine
degrees
oh i made that water okay there's gotta
be a there's gotta be a room
yeah ask it some questions george
martinez
how are you here cause we're all
he has the radio let him do the thing
he's got it
george martinez uh bob did you close
that door yeah i closed the door so you
a-holes would get away from me
we are away from you i can hear you
you're clearly not
oh i leave forever if that's the case is
this toilet
dirty because you have bad poops good
question good question
five emf5 emf f5 dirty water
the sink is dirty the sink water is
dirty oh let me get a pick of that
the sink just the sink just turned
itself on actually in here
look oh thanks for that [ __ ] got it are
you getting emf with
out here i got it right i got it right
outside this wall i'm gonna put a camera
in here in this bathroom
are you an [ __ ] evening
do you like to eat ass he asks the good
questions
i'm getting absolutely nothing on the
radio i think that's a bust
i'm gonna go to the truck and see if i
see anything on the camera okay
doesn't seem to be much of anything
going on here i don't see anything on
the camera right now except for you guys
looking like an [ __ ]
it's a little rude hello no
don't have to wait don't don't don't
respond
can you guys hear me oh god wait can
no
okay so we got a journal
oh orb it's a [ __ ] yeah i saw it
all right well that's the job done boys
all right well i guess we're
we're good to go ghost event bob's
staying there
get scared i'm going back in too i've
got the uh the
smudge stick do we need smudge stick i
think that's one of the objectives isn't
it
no it is not one of the objectives
you already did oh it counted okay cool
all right bob good luck
okay so the ghosts will not enter
hunting mode if there's multiple
people nearby you want me to drop off
this much thick and lighter for you so
you can protect yourself by the way
can someone explain to me what to say
yeah you'll have to be alone for it to
enter hunting mode so good luck
you should grab the crucifix from the
truck and go in there with the crucifix
don't hold it out but just have it ready
there's big spikes in the activity meter
there folks
wait did you guys leave the house
did you guys leave me oh
i'm dead okay thank you oh no uh
guys uh guys uh guys
guys guys can you open the door for me
it would be great if you open the door
can you open the door
well okay yeah you can open the door you
didn't even try to open the door hey
mark you didn't even try to open the
door
oh yeah you think i'm dead so you just
abandoned me
oh he's a lost cause it's not even
trying
oh yeah no you go back in if you want to
i turn around i can't
go that was the plan i literally i
literally get upstairs you drop your
items on the ground i'm like okay i'll
take a picture then you i turn around
you're all gone
and i'm like oh you guys there hello
that was so
good we were literally like maybe we
should just leave
oh my god all right i'm gonna get a pick
this time mark
[Laughter]
all right i got my camera ready
this better be worth it if i if i
survive that just to die again i'm gonna
be very upset the emf is going off
in the van what that's good right
good luck and no one's holding it all
right good luck good luck sean
that was turned off oh i turned off now
that's okay we're fine
i'm trying to witness my crucifix is
gone my crucifix left my hand oh my god
well you didn't witness a ghost event
yet what does this ghost need
you need to be alone well i just came in
because it looked like he was about to
die
all right i just wanted
what's his name george martinez george
martinez george martinez
oh george martinez oh we got flickering
lights
it's here it's here it's yours
picture by the window by the window by
the window i think i got it i'm out all
right see you later
i'm running i'm gonna die now
see ya
uh he's very dead uh guys bob's dead
but good news got a sweet pick well we
still didn't win
i what he meant i didn't witness it i
just saw it right there
i know bob saw it twice all right we got
it
let's get out of here can we see that
what look in your journal show your
picture on the camera should be your
journal
you not only witnessed it you got proof
of him witnessing it and it still didn't
count i got some sweet pics of the uh
scarecrow in the back too
pretty cool huh sam's pretty cool well
you got that
picture that means you had the witness
look yeah
who knows i got a 125 dollars for dying
you got 125 i only got 50 bucks i got
for insurance i got insurance hey we
unlocked large size maps
i saw the picture of the scarecrow and i
was like whoa what a shot
that's not a ghost well you know that
was still pretty cool
i thought it was pretty neat uh-huh
freaking
artsy mark over here you know whatever
it's earthy photographs it was an
opportunity to
express yourself you could never really
like limit yourself
have we done right tanglewood street i
feel like we haven't done that small
three there's a large
floor house with a basement no there's
no large maps why don't we have a large
map i know
we just unlocked no no bob where is it
can i hide in this
oh you can hide i didn't know you could
open these you can hide maybe you could
hide from the ghost
yeah all right we ready all right yeah
let's do it boys
all right do we need anything special
for whatever map selected
no we have everything what do you mean
special what else we're bringing
everything
recommended items no no no we literally
bring everything
dirty water fix emf okay
do we have a crucifix oh look at the
tripod apparently we don't we don't have
a cruiser fix
we don't have a crucifix who didn't
bring a cruiserweight he said we had
everything well we would have you guys
would have brought what you said you
would
i said out loud i don't own anything
anymore apparently well then you were
also the one with 145 dollars
yeah well i bought some stuff
i'm also going in baby wait what's the
name do we know the name
lisa jackson lisa jackson i'll look up
the name
it's lisa jackson it's lisa jackson
okay you also need to be alone for this
one don't mess with the water we're
supposed to find dirty water and take a
photo so don't miss
the sinks i guess the last place we were
i filled up a tank and the water became
dirty so though
that might be a thing yeah so don't
listen to wade he doesn't know what he's
talking about
oh i thought you said the water turned
on you turned it on it did it yeah i
turned it on something
lisa jackson ooh a boat there's a boat
in here get a picture
okay picture oh i don't have a picture i
got something
nice where is this ghost lisa jackson
i heard her in the basement basement
okay coming
i don't know if that counted for
anything i don't think so hmm
nothing down here oh minus one here
minus one here in the hallway
freezing temperatures freezing
temperatures is that our first evidence
yes
it flashed like a second and then went
away
in the basement jackson lisa jackson uh
we do have to be alone i think though
all right
i don't have any sensing equipment if
i'm alone i'm literally not doing
anything
you got it bob good luck oh mine is
eight right here
ooh is it in the closet hallway
no it was here oh if you're here give me
a sign on my radio
i don't think this is the spirit box
ghost hmm oh minus 10 over here
we keep grouping up this isn't going to
work
it's in the baby's room well my breath
was fogging up in the baby's room walk
around with the emf on his own oh yeah
babe
baby's room is definitely uh breath
coldness
go in the babies room it's definitely
baby room are you out of there
yeah go for it good luck what was the
name again
uh lisa jackson please subscribe lisa
lisa jackson how did you die
good camera placement give us a sign
oh my god oh no
oh no
okay all right
no dirty water has materialized yet all
right it says that if it's a phantom
that it commonly possesses living people
and it could be someone with a ouija
board
well we don't have a ouija board lisa
jackson lisa jackson lisa jackson
trying to take a picture of it we'll
make it disappear wait confirm trying to
take a picture of it will make it
disappear or taking
oh right in front of me in the doorway
mark in the doorway
i i saw it i didn't catch it come on
it's flickering flashing it's coming for
i'm dead bye
bye
it looked like an old lady i don't know
if what they look like actually means
much
did we confirm definitely not spirit box
i can go back in with it oh i'll try it
we're here to help we want to help you
oh what we got spirit box spirit box
spear box it said cold here
all right we got a mirror i know what
that is i think it's a female
horse oh don't close the thing yet uh
let me put the thing in
did we get all the objectives no god no
dirty water crew we don't have a
crucifix we could try to do the dirty
water
we looked it's fine did you get bob
stuff
nope no not yet so that's proof that emf
did not go to five that was not an ems
one
yeah we got the spear box i'm also being
told apparently there may be a ouija
board somewhere in the garage
what oh wow we have to find we oh
okay interesting yeah we can't buy one
there uh wait
yeah i'm good mayor bob i hope you have
mayor can he put his journal in when
he's
dead yeah you must be a journalist oh
okay
that way you still get credit for
discovering what it was oh
oh we got it right get shitty on our
objectives
unlock two wait no one got a picture of
the bone in the garage i thought i got a
picture of the bone
you didn't give me credit for it maybe
you didn't get any credit for it but i
guess
we need sanity pills for this we need
sanity pills for the asylum well that
makes sense i guess
uh sanity pills are for level seven
right i don't know sanity pills i can
buy
oh nice i'm gonna buy a crucifix because
we didn't have one of those uh-huh
yeah okay i bought one as well i got
such good pics of that ghost coming up
to you and then a shadow goes so soft
i tried to take pictures of it in the
doorway and i got nothing
dude it was so flashy it was just like
flickering in and out of existence
oh yeah look at this one it's just a
shadow is there like a sick nasty
picture
yeah yeah that's the one that's the one
who killed me yeah you know how
look at my pictures look at all my panic
pictures of an empty doorway that
totally killed my ass
yeah there's the ones that are from
outside the room are marks that have her
in it
the four that are from inside the room
are all mine where i'm just like
oh she's killing me
nice turns out taking pictures didn't
save me
oh i'm being told sanity pills are
currently broken all right
well sanity doesn't even seem like a
mechanic anyway and the
timer countdown is the countdown before
the ghost gets aggressive
oh oh and once we get past amateur we no
longer get a timer
it's just aggressive okay well that's
good i think we're ready
yeah i'm ready is this like a big map
this is a large map oh boy
someone all right hello oh god hello
hello
to my trailer hi why are there no items
hi oh they're there for the trailer hi
how long have you been items don't load
until everyone's here
right okay i was the first one here by
like a few seconds
what is this thing it's a motion center
i bought it it's a motion sensor oh i
got a flashlight in the emf
you can oh you have an emf all right i
want something
i'm a radio man nobody else be radio man
all right okay
i'll be temperature man do we have a
thermometer paul
martin thermometer yeah we got thermo
we've got absolutely
everybody i got some stick together no
mark is the motion sensor
yeah i got the motion well this is a
infrared uh motion says it'll light up
if it sees a ghost
i don't know what this one is oh i want
to take maybe it's the launch codes
oh dude well i don't know what that is
in my hand i have bone evidence we have
to pick up the bone
oh oh [ __ ] oh my god it's so echoing oh
weird oh that's dope that's dope
oh my god oh no i don't like that
oh wow all right good luck guys
how do you know that the ghost seems to
respond to everyone it doesn't say be
alone
the other ones say be alone i would
assume that would just mean it responds
to
everyone talking to it it responds to
anyone yeah i mean the other ones say
make sure
you're alone so we just assumed but
maybe it's not um
ghost is paul martin [ __ ]
martin's a last name it is the last name
but it's also a first name
and it's a middle name my middle name is
martin little known fact
well now it's a very well known fact
don't oversell yourself calm down
[Music]
yeah that's some creepy [ __ ] who's
whistling
[Music]
are these single serve donut containers
is that what this is suggesting
single serve disposable donut containers
what's the person's name please say
something
francine
paul martin i see him hello
there's nothing down here paul martin
you don't even have anything to detect
with
i'm looking with my eyes
isn't it weird the single serving donut
boxes
hmm or something in there yeah i was
just gonna say
paul merton
oh my god that scared the crap out of me
just a yeah just a [ __ ] bob giggle
[Laughter]
it's so hard to just shut up i was gonna
like sneak up right behind you it would
be like
well we're pretty pissed too
are there any non-athletes here
no nope just [ __ ] are there any
ghosts here
well i got my infrared sensor so i'll
put it here
no i'll put it here there we go oh well
it's lit up does that mean
what does that mean oh is it sensing him
no that doesn't make any sense
let me put it on the doorway or
something yeah you guys are
down oh no oh no
ah i missed him [ __ ] mister no he's
there
get out of the way got him no i'm
getting him no i'm getting him i got him
i got him
no that wouldn't know it just i it's an
axe murderer dude
he's not okay i'm not going to look at
him we might die yeah we
guys get here faster can you get here
faster oh hey guys hey guys
uh yeah it was a ghost hey are you in
here you [ __ ]
there any dumbass ghosts in here i i'm
gonna go get the uv
wade where was the cold go over there
over there with them i just want to let
everyone know i got the best picture of
anyone
in this endeavor like i always do
where's the exit
does anybody know where the exit is
oh no i'm gonna die hey do you hear me
yeah i hear you anyone here it's
give me donut i have no idea where to go
to get down here
how did you get out of here oh here we
go
wait it did loop where the hell did i go
five thank you i'm gonna bring back the
hand print uv light i for the first time
ever i didn't bring it with me
i can also bring the journal
what are you guys doing down here it's
fine mark it's fine
okay it's a banshee it has to be well
yeah let me look for thingies
why was that scary you were looking at
me i don't know man yeah there's a
handprint right on it yeah yeah there's
a hamburger get a picture of it get a
picture of it get a picture of it
i got it i'm coming i'm coming i'm
coming
walk walk faster you you tall
i need your assessment on this is this
scary what's up all right next to you
and i just go
[Music]
yeah terrifying that's scary yeah look
terrifying
because it made you sad he's inside me
and they were like oh along and then you
did that
mark you're on my side of this right
yeah i'm on your side you're idiots but
that was pretty scary
uh it was scary but it was still scary
i can't believe we survived man it's
really really easy when you just close
it in a room
well job girls are easily defeated by
doors my ears were
make sure you make sure you do all your
guesses yeah you do all your things
emf freezing and fingerprints yep all
right we're good
go home boys flip it and ship it boys oh
we got everything
holy [ __ ] i wish you could tie up your
other player characters
and then what was he saying welcome back
like some jokes for you where were you
at what are you saying bob
tie us up and watch what happened yeah
what you know you know
you know what i'm talking about no i
wasn't 100 sure
[Music]